what's Your Gut what's your hope as a
scientist as a human how many alien
civilizations are out there hmm
as a ex physicist I'm now much more on
the aerospace engineering side for space
architecture but as an ex ex physicist I
hope it is
uh prolific
I think the challenge is if it's as
prolific as we would hope if there are
many many many civilizations then the
question is where are they why haven't
we heard from them uh and the Fermi
Paradox is there some great filter that
life only gets to some level of
sophistication and then kills itself off
through war or through famine or through
different challenges that filter that uh
Society out of existence and it would be
an interesting question to try to
understand if the universe was teeming
with life why haven't we found it or
heard from it yet to our knowledge yeah
maybe I personally believe that it's
teeming with life and you're right I
think that's a really useful productive
engineering scientific question of what
kind of great filter yeah can just be
destroying all of that life or
preventing it from just constantly
talking to to us silly descendants of
Apes that's a really nice question like
what are the ways civilizations can
destroy themselves
and there's too many sadly well we I
don't think we've come up with most of
them yet that's all they're probably
true that's the thing it's uh I mean and
like if you look at nuclear war some of
it is physics
but some of it is Game Theory it's uh
it's human nature it's how societies
built themselves how they interact
uh how we create and resolve conflict
and it gets back to the human question
on when you're doing long-term space
travel how do you maintain this
dynamical system of of flawed uh
irrational humans such that it persists
throughout time it's not just maintain
the biological body but get people from
not murdering each other and like like
each other sufficiently to where you
kind of
fit well but I think you know if uh the
songs or poetry or books taught me
anything if you like each other a little
too much
um I mean the problems arise because
then there's always a third person who
also likes and then there's the drama
he's like I can't believe you did that
and last night whatever so and then
there's beer gets complicated quickly